foreign
okay
my
I just my right now I got the browser up
I don't have
damn
all right we gotta I got you uh oh
actually doesn't work that way
that's right everybody got these shirts
they hold the line
today is the day
showcase day
let me check my levels
this kid's move is preoccupied with
stuff
we have a 60 Super Chat
from hold on man I gotta put on my
my glasses if this is not happen today
is not here
kids move is uh running them up
we got a 60 60 I guess that's sixty
dollars
elad a slomovic Hold the Line excited to
watch the rising of the Dolphins there
with General Swami David in the realm 60
shakes is 16. oh thank you for the 17 us
thank you
I like I like the 60 the 60 looks crazy
it looks crazy that's what's up
what up
let's go
see Aaron got on his Hold the Line we
live right now
let's go
we'll be watching it on YouTube
4K 60 stream right yeah
I'm watching it on Twitch bro
that's the fast one that's the that's
what I was getting ready to say that's
what I was asking because you're gonna
do twitch
faster
yeah
I'm not trying to be behind we got a THX
1138 with the two dollar Super Chat
General King D-Day is now storm the
beach go go go
[Laughter]
oh Lord we got 328 we should only have
114 likes let's get those likes up this
is your first time showing up
it's gonna be a good day it's a great
day for gaming you know Xbox got to
bring me to save it a situation because
you know we know people wet the bed
boondi remember for 22 months Lord
bronze finally a real showcase enough
respect everyone whoa whoa whoa yes
Bunty
enough respect
now I'm not great with the super chats
but
I'm gonna do my best we have to throw
you the alley oops out here man keep it
rolling
sure
oh I can't watch it on yes what am I
doing
[Music]
don't worry I put the shades on after
the fact but I wouldn't be able to watch
stuff
don't allow you to watch stuff
got all this wonderful stuff here
stay hydrated
while I'm watching the show
a little bit of pineapple juice
foreign
watermelon
Focus
we got 169 likes
well Mr
mdj with the two dollar super Jack king
plus Soul cage plus substitute teacher
fire
we got Matt without fear with the two
dollar uh yo Super Chat bro you got my
Hold the Line vest on ready for the show
thank you for a great show Yo God bless
for everybody that picked up the hold
the line everybody's holding the line
Xbox hold it in line Aaron Greenberg out
there rocking the shirt he's getting
everybody liven up pause
my Fan Fest it's going to be bananas
today bro
it's going to be bananas
this is the show that you did not want
to miss
Trust and Believe
you have people that you know wet the
bed like I said before
put them depends on let's get it man not
this show this show ain't wet in the bed
you gain for a reason
you had some games not TV shows not
movies
[Laughter]
had to see some games 4K 60 baby that's
what I'm talking about it's gonna be a
it's gonna be a movie uh you don't have
to be part of the re-watch game today
baby four cases I want to know how many
people
went back and got their Xbox back
I'm getting rid of my Xbox because man
hold the line man
sit down and hold the line
talking that Madness getting rid of my
Xbox boy it's about to be crazy
421 with only 213 likes let's get those
likes up
man if sour Bond comes out wearing that
shirt everybody I'll pass out
y'all be doing the stream without me
Necromancer Zell with the five dollar
Super Chat watching now yo page on the
big screen today for the Showcase hell
yeah I'm watching it on the little
screen right now but you know I'm gonna
do the re-watch it's gonna be a re-watch
situation with myself
um just looking at everything that I I
missed or stuff that I didn't get a
chance to see Hollywood rules with the
two dollar super Jack came let's go hold
the damn line return of x
yes sir yes sir we outside man oh man
this is it got my boy 108 got my man kid
slope
we got Jay Doug returning yeah people
out there in LA showing out having a
great time I love it Lord I love it I
love it
come on you got on those Ready for War
Crocs yeah
all right hold on let's get these super
chests they're coming in too too crazy
right now and I'm not sovereign so I
don't be holding them all right that's
Necromancer hold on Hollywood rules okay
you got that all right Tony Bryant with
the five dollar Super Chat YouTube
stream is 4K 60 twitch is 1080p that's
beautiful but twitch B early though
yeah facts Corey Tidwell with the five
dollar Super Chat No Lie Microsoft
should be paying you a consulting fee on
God
I'm guarding them from your mouth to
God's ears brother
Gerald Mack with the five dollar Super
Chat all hell IOP
shout out to the Lords at King David
Hold the Line let's go we're in the
theater ready to get it let's that's
right man
yo it's a lot of dudes outside in movie
theaters too this is crazy
it's crazy yo I just saw Transformers
rise of the Beast how was it bro
it's all right so you know Transformers
the movie the the cartoon right and
that's like the seminal movie nothing
can beat it
this joint has gotten
closest
to that feeling
wow
like it's it's stand up and clap moments
it's yeah I'm gonna tell you right now
the the the the second no the first
uh preview well not preview uh after
credit scene
it's going to knock your socks off
if you're one of those 80s 90s kids that
get grew up watching cartoons and stuff
like that it's going to knock your socks
off then the second one is is pretty
decent but
the first and credit score is two
there's two apps yes
two definitely something that you do not
want to miss okay hold on I know Super
Chat just came in
okay hold on oh boy
all right
so all right in jail Mac
we got Spartan six one six six one with
the two dollar Super Chat Xbox is gonna
give it to you hell yeah
we got Dante's Dante valoros I'm sorry
Dante I messed your name up five dollar
Super Chat it's the Lord's day my
medicine is rolled up hold the line
let's get it
[Music]
you wouldn't lie for real
they say J dub all right Jim Ryan's
first party GoFundMe account with the
two dollars Super Chat so pumped my
crown jewels are tingling
tell the truth Shane the devil
we got 20 minutes to kick off
with
531 in the chat with almost 300 likes
come on man
you walk in the house wipe your feet hit
the like button subscribe say
hit the notification Bell
and what happens
[Laughter]
hold on okay jump me
Craig hooligan
remember for nine months Lord bronze
today's a big day and I can't think of a
better place to spend it shout out to
Charlie olives last night oh yeah for
sure
broof I'm still recovering sir I'm still
recovering sir
Wilko falak I'm sorry I messed your name
well tour maybe maybe I didn't fight all
those Super Chat we hold the line like
the 300 Spartans today's the day we go
on offense Jay should hold the line for
the PlayStation Nation I won a valdo fax
though
Gerald Mack with the two dollar Super
Chat salute lemon boss moves we outside
Green Team
hold on did it skip me yes it did angry
hippie with the two dollar Super Chat
did they do
Ace archs oh yeah yeah yeah yeah hold
the line yes they did yes they did they
did them right
all right
Mirage was done rice
um
the the motorcycle chick was done right
all the characters was done right
especially them animals the manimals was
done right my only issue with the movie
is let's say um
the TV show is a uh
uh allotted the ability to use any uh
character that they want because you
know
um they don't have a budget of CGI yeah
the big screen movies has a budget of
CGI so you're gonna get a limited roster
of Transformers where the roster could
have been a little bit more robust and
not to say that they didn't have a large
uh or like budget for the movie I'm
pretty sure that it did the movie um
stands for itself but it it did what it
was able to do with the limited amount
of characters that it did have all right
so you know you're not gonna get all the
Decepticons on the wall or all the
autobots on the wall when it was
fighting you know trying to evacuate
Cybertron or whatever
you're gonna get little scoped uh scenes
scenes that make sense to the movie and
they they narrated the movie Perfectly
to you know to get you to where you
wanted to be to so you can understand uh
what the plot points are and they didn't
reveal their hands too much I'm trying
to say a lot without saying too much for
people that didn't see the movie that's
rise of the trans rise of the Beats
Transformers bone slave was a two dollar
Super Chat Hold the Line IOP baby facts
though
over the line hashtag Hold the Line
it's a beautiful thing oh it's a
beautiful thing my Xbox
was beautiful last night
people don't want to give up people want
to get it
[Music]
let's get it
couldn't even sleep
charge like a kid at Christmas baby you
said you couldn't sleep I didn't sleep
because oh damn
I've been up probably what
20 29 hours
I'll go to sleep after the show
I'm gonna tell you I don't work on
weekends but um so all the stuff that I
don't get a chance to do during the week
hey I'm gonna do it all in one to two
days
that's why I ran out to go see
Transformers I gave her the choice to
see Transformers all go see uh across
the Spidey verse I saw
the you know the Multiverse you know
with you know Spider-Man what you think
about that
I thought it's greater than the first
one I thought it's uh coming to Age
movie for young men I think every young
man needs to go see this film if you if
you feel lost same thing young women too
because it's a it's just a coming of age
woman uh movie for teens if if you don't
think you belong in certain places
you're trying to find your space on life
uh you know your parents don't
understand you and parents should watch
it as well because a lot of times these
kids are trying so hard and they just
don't seem to get a lucky break in
certain things and they don't know how
to talk to you so I think this is a
great movie to go see with your kid if
y'all at that awkward stage where
they're trying to break away and you
you're holding on too tight uh that
thing I think this movie can work those
things out for you but
everything else with the movie is
stellular it's it's a if you're a nerd
junkie comic book junkie like myself
it's Utopia it's absolutely not
um we got Trevor C with the 10 super
chat Day of Reckoning for the
PlayStation Nation Hold the Line facts
though
facts though
oh hold on oh J Dub's in here all right
pause the Legends hold the line you hold
the line movement is real salute King
facts people is out here doing their
best
what's good my brothers oh man he's back
baby that's what I'm talking about baby
that's what I'm talking about
yeah man
oh what's good what's good
for but uh we like that though we like
that over here though big facts dude you
should put back there is uh Forza I mean
uh Gran Turismo the movie
one thing about that we y'all for y'all
forget now no Halo Halo had they they
whole TV show and all that stuff
advertising and they ain't getting no
spots that was the 20-year anniversary
extreme it wasn't the actual the same
thing it don't matter hey hey
y'all was holding out for two years bro
they gave your Popeye biscuits bro oh
man yo and ain't nothing wrong with it
it ain't nothing wrong with you know
what it ain't nothing wrong with it but
what we gonna We not gonna do is we as
Gamers we are not going to accept these
dudes putting together piss poor shows
like like you know
um I was from a PlayStation owner and a
PlayStation fan I was pissed off for
everybody else that you know owns a
PlayStation
um the game awards I know it's politics
are going along in that and yeah a lot
of other
um indie games are shown so the Indie
Games look good
and I like the light that he puts there
yeah Microsoft Nintendo and Sony if
you're gonna make a console you need it
you owe it to your audience to put
together a good show at least once or
twice a year to give an update on what's
Happening and I agree now it's down to
Microsoft to hold the line this is this
is what we're holding the line for we're
holding the line for actual real gaming
first party we want to see full first
parties
is going crazy all right because I'm by
myself doing this guys
hold on
all right it's his second coming you're
ridiculous two dollar Super Chat it's
Christmas time J dub he going to j-dub
that's bad
somebody get king of body bag cause
Microsoft is done
over some with the two dollar and well
2.20 Super Chat Sony dudes new rally cry
after today is retreat wow
hold on Escape me Robert Kelly with the
two dollar super chair got my shirt
ready to hold the line today God bless
you and everybody that got one and even
if you don't got one and you try to get
one or you couldn't get one and you just
hey you hold the line you hashtag and
you're sharing it out God bless man God
bless that you are a part of everything
we are part of a little bit of something
history together
we got almost 700 watching with only 376
likes come on man let's get those likes
up we got J dub in the building listen
if y'all if y'all want JW stay here man
y'all gonna have to hit them lights man
let's get 100 more likes at least come
on
came through on the PlayStation joint
and he came back on the Xbox joint yeah
clowned him but your man is a stand-up
dude and he is here man God bless man
celebration Redemption
[Laughter]
the celebration of the game man we all
here to celebrate gaming and uh
you know it's in in gaming you know you
win some you lose some you're down
you're up just get back up and you keep
fighting and that's why we are here we I
I hope right hand to the man I hope
Microsoft comes out knock it out the
park get back in the game and give us
Gamers uh something to you know
something to talk about for the
foreseeable future we don't want I mean
we sit here and cry all day uh we want
them to come out we want them to be
strong competition is good when all the
gaming companies are doing well
absolutely this is what we're here for
this is what we're here for I know they
better not
little Slaughter me with no third party
yeah
you can't help that no Karma uh hold on
Karma God 91 with the five dollar Super
Chat day job when you're in the realm
respect the gods Hold the Line in case
you forgot
David is the king
so salute to that brother what I'm
saying is of course they got
Partnerships right but when you watch a
first party event
you don't want to be slaughtered by
third party you want to see what first
party's bringing and as a VR owner yeah
yeah they showed me nothing
about Sony joint yeah so I mean I was a
little disappointed in that right like
if you go this is an Xbox event we want
to see Xbox stuff and then Partners
second option that first and anything
you this is not no no no extra show
where you know it's on the side and okay
the deals when you say this is a
Playstation showcase this is an Xbox
showcase nobody
I don't want I want to see Resident Evil
nobody says that
and that's why Sony got that smoke
because that was a PlayStation showcase
right right and so they didn't really
show any PlayStation games uh or you
know Playstation only games I saw the
Spider-Man and stuff like that and they
got the smoke and they deserved it do
not title your your show a PlayStation
showcase or a Xbox showcase if all
you're gonna do is kill other people
games so I I respect that and I agree
with that
10 more minutes Hold the Line
facts eight minutes bro
now now here's the thing
um I'm glad I feel feeling them kind of
came out before the show and and um for
this last couple of weeks and talked
about
not showing CGI and stuff like that we
don't want to see cjr we want to see
gameplay enough for the the CGI Sony
came by and showed number CGI outside of
Spider-Man we don't want to see that
wait wait wait you didn't like foam
Stars you didn't want to play a game
that you're taking a bubble bath
it's a market for it all right if dudes
like Splatoon and games of that nature
hopefully it hits because that what was
that crash team racing All-Star thing
that they had in the beginning that they
sold and then they put on a PlayStation
Service uh that thing didn't take off
and that was one of the games they
wanted to take off so another service
game yeah yeah I don't like the fact
that they're neglecting the PlayStation
Plus owner
like what what did you show that's gonna
uh go day and date inside a PlayStation
plus you know you know they ain't gonna
do that you know they ain't gonna do
that but if that's your third-party
deals you should have at least some of
these Indies that are released day in
day right inside your PlayStation plus
you know Services it's just you know
it's only right we have almost 800
watching with only 400 and some some odd
likes let's get those likes up hold on
TTY
t-y-t-y for Life two dollar Super Chat I
feel the energy this time hold the line
that's what's up man
that's what's up one thing I'll say guys
is
there's no more excuses after this show
this is the show where we're at where
it's you put up or you shut up there's
no more Kick the Can down the road to
next next show or next year or something
like that this is it like come on we've
been doing this for years and years now
so now is the time for Microsoft to
throw all their cards on the table and
just left let the chips fall uh where
they may and and you know and that's
without that's without the ABK deal now
you know next year they'll talk about
stuff with Apk there but right now you
got 27. let's see some from all of that
we got Nicholas brands with the two
dollar Super Chat hold my line pause I
mean hold the line
anybody carry the microphone somebody
over there getting moist
that's a little zesty over here whoa
oh man
a little bit of zesty hey how long is
that uh the Starfield show probably take
another 30 minutes
oops I mean hold the L
yeah that's the same my brother
Christopher what's good let's go he
scraped together those those those those
dollars he got it in there
he was saving them for some some of that
VR shovel where he was like man
the hell the hell would that VR Shuffle
with it I got I'm gonna give it to them
man I don't even want to hear them two
letters VR
Sony want to hear them two letters we
all they want every Playstation only the
head of letters too
but the problem with Sony's uh people
hearing those letters VR Mark Cerny got
your ears
[Laughter]
oh man that might be my worst Tech
purchase in the last 10 years VR what VR
why what's wrong with the VR there's
nothing wrong with the VR they don't got
no damn support for first party
to be dipping
no that's true I mean but to be fair I
mean it just came out like what two
months ago yeah so I mean they got to do
something you gotta you got you got your
horizons seventy dollars
manufactured Horizon of oh and if man
check out this game called red matter
too
um I literally yeah
yeah see but the thing is what he's what
he's explaining Jay
he brought it for first party stuff and
he's looking of course and and I talked
about that but excuse me as early Optics
we know the risk that we run you know we
absolutely front line head out there
head first usually the first ones to get
the defective products be the first ones
you know we're the testing subjects and
we also don't realize they work to a
certain amount of people has purchased
the product install base yeah before
they release those games so yeah you're
sometimes gonna be walking through the
desert looking for some water until they
get that install base and being that
they cut that insole because it wasn't
selling like it was supposed to uh you
know they cut their projections for it I
think you have to wait a little bit
longer for those games well that that
actually came out to be that actually
came out to be incorrect it is actually
doing better than a PS um
psvr uh
I only buy like 20 000 though is that
really I mean that's that's good no it
was about about two hundred thousand
about 200. listen anything
hold on somebody yeah it was Zero
somebody's taking one away what's going
on here yeah anything was better 600 600
000 plus whereas the first one sold 400
000. I mean four six four five six
hundred dollar uh uh accessory
I mean come on I mean I mean it is the
last time that you did something is
always good web day with the two dollar
Super Chat King David what a great panel
hold the line blessings I was trying to
get my boy gas in but he said uh I got a
curse I was like I'm sorry guys I gotta
hold the line
let me see hold on
two minutes two minutes
with the five dollar Super Chat uh Phil
walks out execute execute acquisition 66
the screen goes black and all we hear is
classic Sega two minutes bro hold on
call my God 91 to follow the super Jack
King David the real it's alive period
salute blessings
I'm gonna be honest man enough of the
Acquisitions we want to see the games
from the people that you already bought
like yeah
those Acquisitions it's for four and
five years down the line it's not for
like this day out here
I'm down with you but if they come out
and be like we gotta say good you can
say that today foreign
let's go to show is about to start we
got 32 seconds the countdown is crazy
that's why I told you to watch it on
Twitch and watch it here with us have
two screens
is that soft that just pulled up yes sir
so I don't got to read super chats no
more let's go my coquito Brothers in the
building let's go thank God
thank God the Super Chat was killing me
son and he was like this
here we go
here we go let's go
Microsoft game Studio presents
oh we're finally doing this I mean
because I was gonna make a sandwich
six
let's do it
[Music]
what do I think about heroes
well in the game we've all seen them
haven't we if that's the game I'm gonna
pass the hell out
well they're disproportionately
massive weapons I showed you
nothing else
on a day today
mythical creatures
that's what they are
shut them down
let's face it
Heroes
this ain't no gameplay
already crying
started off with Fable it ain't a secret
no more
hey yo yeah
[Music]
817.
[Applause]
oh kick to the stomach look like they
pray to me baby oh man yeah
oh this thing was looking good yeah
shout out to the 800 watching baby E1
day one on paint passed
Xbox game Studio that's one it's two
the
all right y'all baby father we outside
with the two dollar Super Chat
this is how you do it so
foreign
[Music]
but you got Calvin call a little while
let's get it let's get it
[Music]
look at that rabbit hey man butterflies
no more
no mercy
way down the jungle deep
signified rabbit stuff shaking bones
been a while
[Music]
yeah
oh what's up
I'm looking for a creature
huge sneaky
hell no
it's called a surprise it might be that
new title he said we ain't seen before
surprise
now you've seen it no
this is crazy let's go get it no
nobody I got a joke it was a rock it was
a raccoon and a rabbit in the woods
smiling the power x baby let's go
Jax 82 with the five dollar Super Chat
it's a good rap for places it's a good
rap for PlayStation
and I just start to hold the line
[Music]
oh
I could imagine
[Music]
[Applause]
new title new title been announced you
want to know what they working on they
working on your demise
talk to midnight yeah
day one
game passes World premiere
these are dangerous times
at least that's what oh Ruby saw
I'll teach you how to stop
oh that's looking good baby I
have to play this oh my goodness
massive
Suicide Squad oh man don't do it
PlayStation
oh man baby this is looking good
oh
[Music]
Spartan goes 17 with the two dollar
Super Chat I got a call for the
PlayStation dominance killing them facts
no Phil Dominus Maximus a really
expensive then go to the chap
[Music]
this wouldn't feel like they're watching
show
all right so Chris up Chris oh he's
about to win out
get off my ship Jalen
give me a chance
you're gonna have to yes
risk
it's a little bit of Espionage is in
this look over your shoulder again
[Music]
or a raincoat
hyperspect yo lemani come here bring
that bucket we come
monster
God took 91 July
where you at friends
[Music]
I'm waiting for some gameplay
I came for some gameplay
coming in 2024
gameplay walkthrough
tomorrow
the Xbox game showcase followed by a
deep dive into one of the most important
RPGs ever made Starfield hey she better
not say this coming next 12 months
it transports it challenges it connects
us and it's just incredibly and
awesomely fun that is why team Xbox is
committed to building the greatest place
to play partnering with the most
ambitious of game creators and by
unleashing the power of the Gaming
Community
the lineup we have for you today find a
cameraman incredible
[Music]
for you the largest most engaged and
globally diverse fan base in Xbox
history
you are the heart and soul of Xbox your
passion drives us and you are the
inspiration for The Visionaries whose
games we showcase today
from me and all of the team at Xbox
thank you
this next game is from Thunder Lotus the
award-winning Studio behind Spirit Fair
who've gone back to their combat roots
with an amazing Co-op raid focused
action game that is uniquely theirs
all right everybody it's time
World premiere Thunder Lotus
World premiere
[Music]
well at least they give you something to
the um the services you know they act
like they got a service right
[Music]
it was that game that was popular
um
her um dang I can't think of it
below no it was like a road game uh
didn't make this one right I don't know
okay
pick up and race it has a great
mechanical same art style and stuff it
looks nice I mean whoa could you imagine
Hades with uh four players
it looks more than that yeah this is
actually looking kind of dope I could I
can get with this 33 player 33 player
co-op
oh I guess the cloud do work not like
that SSD
oh man you saw that SSD on Spider-Man
yeah I know I know if we come up with a
PlayStation 4. it's gonna be a problem
out here it ain't it ain't coming for
the PS4
let Jim run let them cook
that's true
[Music]
God damn
33 um
Coming 2024 the game pass
you know what let's make them our Asus
Rog Ally purchase even greater
on Game Pass
I can't wait to get mine to you guys
yeah
oh
that's one of the raw the Ally comes up
yeah yeah yeah now that bro guys
a beautiful Xbox uh Standalone console
and I'll be streaming PlayStation in my
house on it watch what's up with that
everybody okay I haven't played this
like
um is it like Grand Theft Auto because
oh
that's why I just didn't even you know
no it's not going it's not going to go
though no this ain't Grand Theft Auto
this is definitely payday
I said but I never played it I said is
it oh okay but Grand that photo kind of
got the emotes from this
and all that yeah oh so they was doing
this first they were doing it started
off like that okay yeah it's a fun game
online
I've never played it I I would love to
but but now you got a chance
the problem of course
yeah I'm definitely rocking this baby
that was nice though yeah I mean it's
not for me it's not for me but it looked
nice I mean for those people that do
like payday
you look dope
crazy Co-op a lot of stuff is happening
yeah
you know pulling out cell phones calling
strikes and PayDay 3 yes oh September
21st
Game Pass day one play it in Game Pass
day one
leave your wallet at home and watch the
show
here
[Music]
that's all this is
no no
persona 3.
[Applause]
oh oh
yeah oh remake oh
yeah though but it looked good over here
though we wasn't supposed to hear that
though oh look at that Sticky's private
second foreign
it don't matter it's dead
oh we won
we want this we do that
world is shrinking my boy Bloody real
excited today baby
you don't even have to cross the street
to play Persona anymore remember that
remember that you have to turn on your
little white box that's sitting there
with the wings you know outside
yeah you might be like hey man it's
another one I ain't gonna turn you on
for man sit down man ain't nobody call
your name sit down let's go
Game Pass
read your wallet at home services
videos let's get it oh man what's this
water looking shimmery
oh your man look product
wait everybody
what is this
yeah
people don't like you very much
oh man yeah open the door let me see
what's inside
oh
wait oh he charged up pistols on boy he
drove down on him
ran up on the wrong dude thought it was
just Sergeant Shields I got the blicky
that's what Phil said to y'all y'all
thought it was shorts and shields
[Applause]
giant spiders
zombies you scare us
please Asian ain't got it no
J dub this is what they paid for right
five years ago right
[Music]
this is true everybody's dead right now
let's go uh necromancing at his finest
look at that
yes they showed up yo yo yo we're
already full
[Music]
Game Pass
this game
oh
okay okay we gotta have seasons the
money maker baby 35 million people
you know
Star Wars Monkey Island Monkey Island
okay that's what's up
we got 900 blocks but we knew this was
coming though we knew some change like
let's hit that like let's hit that
subscribe let's share that out let's let
everybody know what we talking about we
talked about holding the line baby a big
ship a luxury a ship with just a spoon I
told you we was cooking Man legend of
Monkey Island
I told you no autographs
the lights you know what Monkey Island
is unnatural yes it's not everything
that you get to me
yeah
that was fun we did that that's crazy
did the missions ahead of time and then
came back and then showed us
let's all figure it out together
Christopher heart cartoons okay
[Music]
don't act like you don't be doing the
slave dance to see a thieves at night I
know you do stop playing you're playing
every night just like me
on our secret stock account
let's go games games games games
stuff for free
let's go July is lit so that's just
around a quarter Premiere this party
my videos
baby
let's put a little estobo on it
the Next Generation Microsoft flights in
pursue your dreams in the aviation
career
oh
so it's fighting
oh oh
put out the wildfires that are actually
hurting New York DLC DLC that's right
man this game out there look beautiful
baby y'all gotta play Slim no
yes
yeah man slide that in there Paul look
at that water
look at that Man helmet
look at the wheels
baby
oh look at the reflections on the on the
on the tarp
it's rainbow
they say yo we doing this cause you
can't
[Laughter]
they said we give you some DLC cause
y'all don't know how to put out games
jumbo jump off looking crazy
you can go to the Antarctic I've never
been there I can try that
[Music]
a little one on my flight stick
just kidding start flying let's get it
let's go let's get it hey why go buy Ace
Combat
go back to the projects where you came
from
oh they had the new flying car in there
y'all saw that yes sir did they have the
Sony car that they showed on that show
this dude Petty as hell man who is this
50 Cent
what's in your cup Jacob needs some too
wait a minute what's this oh
that look like Doom that's from dude
and the movie come out this year too so
you get the chance to play that in
Flight Sim
see this is how you show movies without
showing actual movies
[Music]
yeah
sometimes I dream
that he is me that's how our dream life
is supposed to be
[Laughter]
what you'll see today is all captured by
the team let's go Facebook series
there's a lot of you duels will be
looking for games
Ninja Theory in-game footage footage
okay
hey Spider-Man
where you at by the minds off
Spiderman
they got Spiderman from New York
I want to hide
in-game footage so far this is five this
is five first party
welcome to the party
better not be the game place look look
she got smoke she got smoke from the
mouth
stop
oh man Horizon who
oh man
somebody said hold somebody said
somebody said walking simulator nerd
meat head with the two dollar Super Chat
Xbox throwing hey man they going for the
kill
ER
they got the chill week they try to
knock him out in the first round
the black Harry Potter Super Chat
he said I can't even lie this showcase
is murdering some of these everywhere
Sony shows trash
Game Pass foreign
[Laughter]
that's an eyeball
s
oh it's 12 times
oh my God I got tears in my eyes oh my
God
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you Lord
somebody was on the wrong side of
History
if you don't dare to be great they will
never remember your name build dominance
Maximus are really expensive first of
his name
your dudes are done son I told you the
rise of dark field
oh man both the lock two dollars sell
your eggs sell your PlayStation 5 Xbox
is the best box everything I don't know
let's go we got 932 watching with only
600 some odds likes moving get those
likes up I'm giving you bars
no
no oh man
they gonna show some fun back
they showing you what they can't get
over there
Corey Taylor Super Chat
let's go
[Music]
that's next year so it's not November
we know what it is next year we know
what it is
we got the killers
oh
oh what's this
like a dragon like yeah like a dragon
the the one that Sony show
s
17 two dollars Dave Doug looking
deflated give him some water
yo that girl got a BBL now what's going
on
[Music]
[Laughter]
is wild
laughs
hey y'all know y'all know Twitter I'm
gonna be talking about this all day come
on yeah they don't have to because they
ain't got nothing
that's right it's that time
yeah man got two percent body fatty on
the beach
this better not be Game Pass
yeah let it be Game Pass baby Sega
yeah
uh-oh yeah
okay oh
[Music]
oh
call a 76 Fallout 76 15 million people
have been playing
[Music]
headed for the board
we got 721 we almost got the one-to-one
ratio let's get that 100 and more let's
do it let's do it let's get this like
let's try to get a thousand likes before
the show is over that's you know put the
notification hit the like button
subscribe share that out to a friend
give me some fun bars Atlantic City if
you've ever been to Atlantic City what
goes on in the ball walk stays in the
ballroom
well I'm gonna be honest
but because of Starfield
I don't want to see nothing about no
fall out right now
Capcom
[Music]
nah
what the hell or something uh something
I don't know Castleberry is Konami no
that's Konami
oh goals and goals
it might be a new IP
ad I can't even figure this out
because they did say World premiere so
Ani Musha that'd be wild that'll be wow
wow yeah right because we haven't heard
that what the hell is this
this is new YP that's what it looked
like something new something new
what's up with the mask the mask was
crazy right yeah
what nah man
ready
I'm not saying I'm liking this this is
crazy yeah I'm not saying that it's a
little whack I'm just like yo old boy
came out
look Wild
I'm in for new stuff so it is
[Music]
yo
I mean put some Game Pass I'll play it
what is this past
yeah there's something new I like that
this is definitely a Game Pass game yeah
man you can't say that that game look
good bro no no I'm not saying that it
don't look good I'm just saying Xbox
game studios presents hold on we are
another one let him cook son let him
cook they got 30 students
it's the first next-gen game that's
gonna be out baby it's all Spiderman
it's on October 10th right before
Spider-Man punch Spiderman look at that
car look at that car look at the car
with its Thunders
uh the first uh the legendary Corvette
no no we're talking about real for
decades this gen the all-new Chevrolet
Corvette
out of both consoles foreign
look at that man hell yeah game footage
look at this man
this is what I'm talking about I know
you're ready
baby be ready
not impressed
the movie even better it's great when
you can have a movie via Olympic sport
you know what I'm saying that's what
everybody ain't able everybody
oh I know you outside of this I know you
outside I see that Grace tracing race
give me that the release date
October 10th
now
[Music]
I just want y'all to know October 10th
what I said
I'm a die hard racer I know yo this is
what's up most people race uh with the
Horizon series because it's it's the
same because the sun's casual it's
Arcadia yeah it's casual
simulation guys so hold on that's mine
XT with the five dollars and 50 Cent
super chats all this shown already what
could they possibly be ending the show
with this show is fire on God and them
bro tell the truth the red fall package
the 60 frame patch
oh there's got to be Elder Scrolls
Online Elder Scrolls
Elder Scrolls Online
and I had to stop I just had to stop I
got a um vampire werewolf uh
I don't have time to play fortnite
Destiny and this I just don't and I
haven't been on Destiny in a minute and
I gotta jump back in new season starter
before night is being real cynical bro
yeah October that was that was it I hate
it ahead of time
you came to the realm alone much respect
man definitely man he's not alone
brother I'm home with his brothers man
ah you know that was an invite you know
we give him that courtesy if he's gonna
sit there and take the ribbon for his
show he can come here and rip us on ours
man
I told you
yeah Kelly too long Xbox showcase is the
whole L get off my butt off I feel bad
for y'all skills I'm gonna need that
brother to change his name brother well
he's telling the truth
you came back to get your legs taken
again
and you got a PlayStation VR so a lot of
that stuff spoken
here and there
I can only I can only do one or two
Services games man I can't I can't I do
three at a time Battlefield Halo and
Call of Duty I love Halo a long long
time ago to do uh fortnite and Destiny
and I've been slacking on my desk it's
just too much and unfortunately
yeah well I'm in a membership of the
fortnite right a fortnight yeah
[Music]
on us
hey they need a family plan man because
I got my three sons
that's right you got to defend them deep
up they don't want money they want
v-bucks though
they ain't got time to grind they want
what they want that's right I want V
bucks man I'm like what I'm not playing
OverWatch until it feels like a real
part too
oh
[Music]
what is this
oh okay what the hell is going on that's
this RPG that attic like
they're attacking us smooth what you
eating over there brother
all right this is oh
yeah all right
Shadows oh my God is this really Xbox
been rocking since Halo of course
[Music]
I know Adam gonna play this
unfortunately
Persona tactical yeah
comes out this year Game Pass
[Music]
a Game Pass day one man
this this is this is good that Xbox is
finally getting
um the Persona games yeah hell yeah
because a lot of people yeah hold on
Bethesda what's this
so
I don't know well this show they show
the game and if you want to stick around
for the Deep dive into the game
so you think that so is it you think
this the last one like this is kind of
going out
is it a separate show is running on it's
a separate shows it's a separate show
okay so it's like runoff like after we
finish watching this show
for the next show I feel like you want
to stick around and
we'll be you know going to do dive or
Starfield we're all here because we're
committed to the biggest question of all
I'm I'm super intrigued by what this
game is going to present
okay
now they're showing the space going into
planets
[Music]
walking around look like we meet you
you're part of constellation
no man's sky so you know no man's sky is
definitely dope I didn't know what to do
in the beginning it was terrible yeah
but see I got it later on when they had
pictures right no final groups
this is looking fantastic it looks
ridiculous this is looking crazy this
looks ridiculous but this looks awesome
everything we've been looking for you
think it's gonna be 60 Minutes
I don't you might put a mode in there
but he prefers 30.
but it's not about it's not ours he's
making a game yeah that's it it's a
developer yeah he wants his artistic
Vision so whatever artistic vision is
this game is ridiculous walking
yeah this is crazy spacewalk
yo they should they showed it before
yeah I tried to steer winky stuff
oh I'm with this this looks crazy
[Music]
with the two dollar Super Chat they got
rid of the PlayStation 3 Graphics let's
go facts I think there was placeholders
I wasn't too impressed the first time
but now I'm impressed with this
we got 982 almost a thousand people with
781 likes let's get those likes up if
you come in wipe your feet have a good
time uh
Hold the Line
September the 6th we outside September
the 6th just another game I've been
playing on my Ally yeah
and I know
it wasn't it ain't open smooth it ain't
over
oh what is this
[Music]
what was that climbing that rock every
while
[Music]
they improved it like crazy hell yeah
they did with the time that they had on
it no lie
what is this
what is the take on Zelda
I got some breakfast
listen I I don't listen I like the art
style man I like the art style I like
anything that's different than trying to
be what is supposed to be something
separate from everything else give me a
new experience every time I am a sucker
for those realistic graphics
you got this little chair rub on his
shoulder this is weird though look like
you got a little um
I think this is ever Wild
I don't know
because they would have said they would
have said it yeah yeah I don't know what
this is
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you this this look like
it's going straight for Bluff of the
Wild's throat
oh they already choked it out
took it out graphically
the gameplay
at this point the line is holding itself
two dollar super jet PlayStation 5 is
holding Starfield back
let him cook
this dude look good
yeah
so hey if you got Nintendo switch and
you ain't like the Vaseline Graphics we
got a home for you oh man an Xbox
One games
oh my God
they cooking
let them cook oh
what
what the Super Bowl
what are we gonna do
a secret secret move he said batting
down the hatches
he is getting rough out here these dudes
would have gone to a nice fight
who does
para me two dollar Super Chat damn
people out here cut throats
laughs
okay
[Music]
who's this
what the what's going on
he left on the freight outside by
yourself
[Music]
leave your wallet upstairs get my wallet
on vacation B free up some services
have you seen my wallet tell them to
keep doing what he's doing I ain't
falling
this is crazy we almost got a thousand
people watching we got uh 804 likes
let's get those lights up let's come on
we need two more 200 more uh oh what's
up
uh-oh what's going on here what's this
this looks fantastic
hey J dub you like art style I got style
after was out for you
what you say before game Game Pass
hey what's up with that PlayStation Now
service thing
over there
in 12 months they buy their games they
buy their games yeah they can keep
buying them I'm cheap
[Music]
you can't
Spiderman and no service I already
pre-ordered that dude I already know how
y'all guys right I know you guys
hold on hold on hold on Johnny
silverhead is it finally happening in
the upcoming expansion first cyber oh
this is
yeah the Phantom Liberty Liberty
Liberty Liberty
let's go
check it out
who got the marketing rights
Johnny
now the biggest question is is this
gonna be in game Paris oh man I don't
know PC
's box
settings
that's right as it's called the dev kiss
my name is
called a development kit that's what
they make games on
development kids PlayStation games
aren't born on PlayStations they're born
on PCS imported to PlayStations like
everything else
PC rules same thing with the switch they
have Dev kits bro man's got a thousand
and one reasons to want Myers as a
hostage
this little guy
I need to get off the third level
right there yeah that's why that's what
I told you he's the face of this uh just
DLC he was saying that he wanted him
there instead of piano
time
of the year is foam Stars two dollar
Super Chat they will allow Jim Ryan we
allowed to go
yeah
oh I'm loving this they look good
I still got to find the base game bro
I'm at like 45 to 10 or something like
that I'm not jigged up listen I got like
three hours a day to play I think
no no no no
they'll just look crazy
look crazy
just one word Songbird yes that looks
crazy don't put your head the situation
has changed
illusion of Freedom draws in the desk
hey yo I honestly think that that stuff
had a lot of things you know going wrong
when that marketing team pushed first
the release dates and stuff like that
yeah
23. let's go let's see if it's Game Pass
nope
[Music]
let's go
what though is this
every road what is this road simulator
[Music]
they did those little Sim games and
stuff those little God games
Age of Empires for me boy
[Music]
they need it they need a Next Generation
Age of Empire man that Asian empire did
you see it did you play it
yeah that thing is kind of crazy
I mean I I understand it's a the it's a
little bit outdated and not part four
what would it bring it's not outdated I
mean the formula I was talking about
yeah
yeah I'm talking about a next-gen brand
new engine and everything bring it up to
bring it up to Modern stuff where it's a
next Gene game I'm not talking about the
the bones of the old in this building
yeah yeah
you can still tell them you can still
tell the elements of the the old engine
and stuff like that just like this this
looks phenomenal if you want to be a
city planner you happen to want to be a
mayor in your life
you want to know how the sewage systems
work we got a game for you
not me buddy
I know what city
yeah of course boy Game Pass looking
real hardy out here that Mill's feeding
us huh I'm telling you they bring Sarah
Bond outside she go big fish hunting
keep feeding you fish hunting let's go
because I'll put that there
yeah it's crazy for your services World
World premiere
y'all they ain't got nobody talking they
just showing games
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
come on yeah I was getting ready to say
it looks like a person yeah from the
makers of persona games
[Music]
looks like it goes well with the wrong
challenge
[Music]
oh my God this is looking like they
stole PlayStation Souls
[Music]
something in the building no
setting the link to solved he's been
sitting there trying to get in that's
called metaphor
World premiere World premiere
let's let's go imagine Checker
oh Xbox man I heard you was cooking
from the creators of the band of saga
trilogy
Humanity's cities
in the belfry
we must explore this world
to find the origins of this hey now
Run for the hills the green notes are
coming
explore a co-ops let's go baby yes
everybody
new world
[Music]
so it's a 2d 3D side stroller
what is the size yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
did not arrive in time damn it and I see
Smooths didn't arrive either sorry
Aaron Greenberg's did though it
definitely did it definitely did
I
stopped watching around Fallout 76 but
up until then
[Music]
everybody seem to be working over there
at Microsoft
I saw a lot of Xbox first party Studios
dude I did more than five seconds
the house of Wonders
my apologies everyone I was uh driving
back from set out to Springfield
Massachusetts I surprised lady saw last
night with a Bruno Mars concert she was
very very happy awesome
shout out to Bruno Mars yo he don't
there's no phones in his you can't
record it yeah no pictures no nothing
huh
lemani give me that gray Poupon
look at this man
makes you
wondering anywhere else
my mind was the last one that came in
yes sir
I was doing the Admiral job by myself
that's why I got on the glass
House of Wonders very steam punkish
control the future
we control the future there's no Sony
very Bioshock
send him the way of Sega make them a
third party app
remember this is how it happened
Clockwork Revolution
did they announce both uh both guys on
the games huh both Persona games yeah
right yeah yeah they did yeah
I'm excited to see 11 games showcased
from our first party Studios we opened
with Fable from playground games which
will bring the franchise into the modern
era while staying true to its British
style and humor
compulsion and an exile shared their
first original experiences since joining
Xbox with south of midnight and
Clockwork Revolution
and we are thrilled at how a vowed is
shaping up for release next year from
the RPG Masters at obsidian
in addition to about our Studios will
deliver hellblade 2 an all-new Microsoft
flight simulator towerborn and More in
2024.
later this month players can look
forward to Elder Scrolls online necron
and sea of Thieves Monkey Island
as we look to Holiday we will launch
star field and Forza Motorsport both
built for Xbox series X S and PC we are
also honored to share 14 games today
from our creative Partners like Star
Wars Outlaws from Ubisoft massive in
collaboration with lucasfilm games
33 Immortals from Thunder Lotus
kunitsugami path of the Goddess from
Capcom and more Persona games coming to
Game Pass thanks to our continued
partnership with Sega Atlas
I'd also like to congratulate the studio
zero team on metaphor re fantasio it's
great to be able to Premiere what is
next from the creators of persona here
in our showcase we are focused on
putting our players and game creators
first in everything we do
no matter if you choose to play on Xbox
PC or over the cloud all gamers are
welcome here at Xbox
when it comes to PlayStation Players
let's go we have heard your feedback on
two fronts let's go first we have
significantly increased our supply of
Xbox series X making it easier for fans
to find globally
second
we know you've wanted more storage with
Xbox series s and I'm excited to share
we have some news there as well
a new series
[Music]
let's go
oh
whoa
I'm sorry my bad baby
[Music]
oh
okay
e let's go
349.
I knew right before star field comes out
one more thing I've been waiting for
anything else for the most comprehensive
deep dive we've ever done for the
biggest game we've ever built the one
more sit tight and enjoy Starfield
Direct
[Music]
okay
okay that's the one more thing that's
fine
yeah they wouldn't Buck bananas
it's a hard hard selling they still
exist man performance so you got those
super chats race up I got them don't
worry about them
do that
no doubt we almost got a thousand people
we're here we got 800 and sometimes
let's get those lights up let's hit that
let's hit that like subscribe and
notification buttons hey fellas I'm
about to get ready to drop out all right
let me get ready to drop out salute to
all y'all brothers man appreciated
what's your number you gave to show
cause I gave the PlayStation three a
three thank you so much today and
welcome to yeah that's the game studio
so you only you only give us one more
than the PlayStation stuff because
you're getting Playstation yeah because
they didn't show the graphical stuff
never tried to make a game like this
today you'll get to hear from many on
the team and see so much
our game special so let's jump in and
take a look
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
but it's still a Bethesda RPG through
and through where you step into a new
world and you get that feeling of
unlimited possibilities
but this time it's not just wrong
because the choice of where to go it's
not ours it's yours
all right and it wasn't until now
yo refantity refanted these snort the
line
Kings remember for 31 months
and King We Trust hashtag Line Health
that isn't just a background right that
moon is actually there weakening the
planet yes you can visit it too I don't
know if you saw Assad but the new Atlas
IP is coming to Xbox and Gamepad that's
fantastic I ain't see a six though it's
fantastic
news is real time
yeah that's funny
that usually involves explorers
go you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
you know I would read it R Kelly but
it's obviously I think I forgot Kelly
Two Dollars Xbox having the worst show
than song horrible horrible
person to please
this looks crazy
this looks insane
I like when you hit that they they uh
the little jet pack in the back
we do love stuff and
you can view all that in your data menu
just obsess over the details and food we
obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back
we have Companions
and he can even say your name give a
time frame
though
our mission was to convince and the
Majesty of space exploration to evoke
the Romance of the golden age
and we've been referring to this
approach as it's a road
advanced yet
contrast that's where the visual
interest is obviously the NASA which is
the rigid pod function over style oh and
everybody asked me what I had in my cup
style I have Focus graphics
what's the plan this looks sickness this
looks incredible
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on oh God
further you can view all the planets
obviously the game is big and it's here
you can see planets that have key
locations missions or life on them
versus the many planets that are Barren
but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems in this part of the Galaxy here
you can probably be worse to ones that
are light years away
to fold space and jump to these systems
you will need to upgrade your shipping
skills if you want to jump to the most
distant ones but for now we'll plot a
course to the Alpha Centauri system
where we can find the city of New
Atlantis
oh wow
this is still look
I like that
of course
[Music]
look at the detail in the ships it's
crazy
and this is all ships that you can build
yourself as soon as you land yeah like
new Atlantis your eyes are divided
upwards to just these boundless vast
buildings the biggest city we've ever
made not just in size but also in the
amount of custom art
crowds and quests
so the main focus when we're designing a
city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day lives it's paralyzed if
you really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
this does look like a step up from what
Todd usually does
[Music]
and stuff
if you could place it on the table but I
understand like
if it's part of you Millions
the ex Soldier and Adventure now
constellations lead Mateo the Theologian
who believes that there's definitely
something else
the gifted scientist and Sarah Morgan's
Protege and Walter a very successful
businessman in the settled systems and
constellations financier anything goes
as long as you have the money
the former Space Cowboy
you know what I hate about these times
the journey you take with constellations
and Adventures for you to uncover oh my
God
[Music]
we're actual controllers
discipline and the legacy of humanity
they consider themselves
new Atlantis isn't the only reason
to this day
initially they were going out quick
everybody was getting this stuff invest
in the week then all of a sudden beyond
the United States you might find
yourself
as well and this is
City
appreciate it I appreciate it
fixture wearing a shirt and Fan Fest you
know a ranger relies
platform but is now known throughout the
city held the line today that's a
pleasure City
you've got morality issues
they kept showing first party stuff
that's what I really see that's right
that's right
[Music]
by Neon
they show
probably going to the game pass right so
I get it I get it face oh this is the
face
looking way better than he did before
they think the Galaxy is theirs they are
wrong it belongs Crimson Fleet
that you know uh okay
we're pushing our cities and settlements
further than we've ever happened
for details a slice of Humanity's future
that they took to to get it together
ready to get out there
his hands I'm the type of person who
spending hours in character creation
because you know people are going to be
really excited
one of the biggest overalls was done
through our character generation system
we scanned a wide range of faces from
different groups
characters
we use that exact system to create all
the characters and NPCs you're gonna see
in the game so any character you see
project Aries so many BBWs in the dev
Team game gonna be wow what the heck
whoa come on
look at the details
mentally the jury's still right
you know who you are new recruit for
Argos extraction this is Todd's own
engine right any of this looks familiar
ity
and that'll be your starting point
your journey from there can be as
detailed or as quick as you want it to
be this new system has more to offer
than ever people into an engine that's
already pre-built like unreal or um it's
also the simplest customization is crazy
let the player get as close as possible
to make whatever they want with it and
that's a big thing for a lot of people
sometimes they don't get black people
scars piercings teeth setting right it's
a lot but I think it's the most fun to
use and everybody should you know
character creation is more than just how
you look this is also where you start to
decide who you want to be that's where
backgrounds come in
skills
molecule
[Music]
a visitor
visitor
came across some hostile zealots in
space because I had chosen a trade that
made me the same religion I was able to
get by with all that many issues
there's another great one that gives you
a damage Buffet
if I get used to just get by the face no
matter what you choose there'll be
plenty of ways for you to tell your
story and if you want to remove a trait
there are ways to do that
it's a feast for the eyes
the next out of Worlds could be that
sort of opens your game right yeah
look like cyberpunk in space
Captain America's approved this damn
message let's go let's go once you've
built the perfect character that's when
your journey can really begin
we took what we loved about skills and
perks from our previous games and put
them together to create an all-new skill
system they work hard each time okay
that's what I want to see alien life
thank you
early in life
what is going on with this species on
this planet
you know you go to different planets
it's a different species it's different
challenges become increasingly difficult
as you work your way to higher ranks
with our five different skill trees and
four ranks per skill there's a lot to
choose from now mind you guys I'm not
listening technology because it lets you
mind control aliens
purely off the visuals and what I'm
saying who's back out of the gate I'm
boost packing everywhere that was crazy
yeah
that's fine I like maxing out mine
strikes and just punch my way through
combat you know it's
[Music]
[Laughter]
jumping out and swinging on people oh he
got the
fine I'll make sure you're an access
card I'm more of a run and Gun player
three in space I like doing that yeah
thing where I boost pack over guys and I
throw landmines at them
shotgun
hey Chris I needed to see that action
here you go
a room with the grenade yeah close the
door this is for you
[Music]
oh man
Spider-Man sword in Spades
oh my god there are four star systems
with new life resources and Adventures
you want a piece of me old man no
[Music]
you want some of this little man you got
to strike a balance between being fun
and realism
all right girls
from the day we approached planetary
atmosis
PlayStation suitcase in the first 15
minutes of the show
rejoicing feels greatness
hell yeah everybody's held in lies
ha ha ha
you'll be navigating asteroid Fields
with interesting strangers
this is crazy
it's gonna be a it's gonna be a life
ticket all out there you won't be here
forever man they'll probably put my foot
ultimately uh it's about rewarding your
face because I'm playing Diablo right
now another one that takes your life
you'll never see me playing
I'll send you messages
[Music]
yes
I almost got moist hold on man
thanks to yourself
the notifications
no I was picking mine up anywhere on my
way to work
anything I can help you with
um for the Speedy fighter that's perfect
for bounty hunting
then you might round out your ship
roster with a hulking space
didn't just drop the meat on the table
he dropped the whole damn horse
[Laughter]
you can customize enough for you
everything you see here
oh
adding a new habitat module can give you
more room
adding calories
and control rooms
animals
[Laughter]
the HMS company
trained on your head boy you brought a
knife to a gun spider bang bang next
it is
home
[Music]
four feet and legs
remember the first time
yeah I was like what yeah they got it
right with the so you got a member of
the constellations
we'll be traveling together until we
either find an artifact or this lead
Runs Dry
[Music]
each companion comes with their own
valuable skills for your ships
as well as unique quest lines eventually
some friendships might blossom into
romance I don't know that I've ever
really loved anyone except you and if
you're looking
you can always hire additional crew at
spaceports got any room on your ship or
someone like oh look at the bubble
bubble Jack and the crazy sneezing like
nuts what is it that they had September
assigned crew to yourself and their
unique skills will affect how they run
oh
[Music]
Brazil
Ian
man just got a waist trainer on with
legs
[Laughter]
but just
look at this no Squad score down in that
house
[Music]
pretty much anything and that is really
cool for us as developers PlayStation
new that's why they try to lock the
space flight should be exciting and
dangerous and you should feel like
you're in complete control every step of
the way
we already have a suit here we've
extended that sense of control to ship
combat it's not about just hitting your
triggers to fire your weapons how much
might I ask it's a complex dance
[Laughter]
23. two dollars
bodies
before you can make a jump oh yeah
I told you
you should go on your toes look at the
shield right on the bottom right that's
crazy yep
you like Star Trek you're definitely
gonna be ahead you know I mean Star Trek
it's crazy Captain Kirk is my idol
he's known across the Galaxies
for all his children
his Royal loins
I'm surprised
yeah
because you come on man how many times
do you you're outside trying to shoot
somebody remains
you can always turn any that
engages you into scrap
all right
take everything from them but you could
also take a more personal approach by
docking with the Enemy vessel and
boarding their ship
okay
give me the booty
where for the booty once you've taken
control of an enemy ship it's yours
added to your Fleet and retrieve it at
any Spaceport
your life
well that's something else
seven five dollar Super Chat we held the
line and we were rewarded hashtags hold
the line yes talk to the crew maybe you
talked into buying a whole new sex a
civilian ridiculous this is better than
what anybody thought was gonna get I
mean this is
and the thing is with these games it's
always about the moments of Discovery
like when you're out there right yeah
there are plenty of personal encounters
to be had as well people was happy with
mass effects
when I'm playing I generally go crazy
um I definitely go like the more piracy
routes I want to take over ships I'm
going to board ships I'm like this is
now mine I steal all these sandwiches
and put them you know also specifically
for sandwiches
but I want to go out and just start
taking things for people as quickly as
possible yes 95c oh some strangers might
be looking for human connection
oh but I haven't had a chance to mess
with it too much it'll ride because we
left Friday it arrived Thursday so I set
it up there I was up to like 4 AM
messing with it and then I had to leave
Friday morning so the thing after show
today
it goes into game mode but I haven't
a hard line to it yet I want to see I
want to see the stream directly on that
see how that runs but it's all in there
just make your own path
there are over a thousand planets
we want you to feel like explorers
breaking ground on new planets this is
incredible Man
Xbox did great incredible showcase Xbox
and wonder
oh
when you land I want to see these crazy
different Vibes oh the Spanish
girl this is crazy
I love I love what they're showing that
that you know the game is versatile
everybody we've shown you so much stuff
a little bit different you know we put
so much detail into our game world and
we love the opportunity to bring that
into the real world with our Collector's
Editions and for this game uh we've done
it give it to me it is a whole
constellation explorers watch
um this is the watch that you actually
get in the game that acts as part of
your HUD where it's the compass and then
environmental information
notifications and other information
mechanism authentic heavy
hatch native strap and the overall
function believability
what exists in the world in the
Starfield universe
how much we actually have something else
so right now
this custom limited edition Starfield
controller it's awesome it is now you
know our favorite controller I love the
controllers
that's a pretty controller
headset with Xbox
you know
I had said book somebody did a thing
oh as you snap it in half on on the show
location
all right where can we get this watch
man what's up
look at that
all right so that's the trailer that we
saw the show was over more than likely
we got rock out 23 once again
I'll be damned if you know you know
that isn't just a Bethesda games TV
world it's a Bethesda everybody's you
know like stick around General
his appearance he doesn't want to give
you the freedom on a galactic level the
views on the show freedom to experience
both the exciting planets
and The Quiet Ones
scanning a planet before you land is a
great way to get a sneak peek at the
available resources you can use for
crafting building and customizing I
think what's cool about this whole
system that we we generate the planet
itself
but the handcrafted content itself comes
as the player Explorer
our system builds a planet as the player
approaches it and we stitch together
luck of terrain after that we have the
system that adds interested movements
for the player to explore creatures to
encounter that's what I like I like
wearing the plants to pick up
it allows us to add that touch of
environmental Stories the tester is
known for
teachers have been disrupting our
experiments their habitat isn't far from
here if you could take care of them for
us we would be in your debt so even if
your friends were to visit the same
planet that you had you would have a
different story to tell
wow regular prostitution
you know how I do I just walk away from
seeing stuff so
this stuff looks crazy to me so it's all
new I'm re-watching right after this
goes off yeah yeah I'm gonna watch it in
4k oh yeah oh yeah I'm going upstairs
I'm gonna put it on the LG you know what
I do
bye bye buddy
see they got the levels next to their
number the numbers for their levels next
to the characters
backpack it's a shot of it to the
ceiling
look at that
with the help of your scanner you'll
chart the Android
exotic wildlife
a few amazing have the skills
and figure out that so remember guys
and you can purchase resources financing
animals and you can get experience and
rewards
Game Pass
right you must spend seven hundred
dollars
that makes sense to you guys
something you've never seen before
creatures looking crazy
when it comes to our exteriors when the
sun moves all that light is calculated
in real time through the atmosphere our
biggest goal for lighting with Starfield
was to make the game feel more filmic to
use lighting and color to really make it
feel more cinematic
[Music]
after some exploring you can find a spot
to set up a base camp
outposts can be built almost anywhere on
any Planet well you can build your own
outlet and the habitat monsters come in
all shapes and sizes
space on your own little place
for added bonuses and set up extractive
what do you think you think it's 60 or
30.
larger parts of the Outpost and placing
those larger halves that way you can
really use that plan your structures
much easier
[Music]
now that the series s is one terabyte
you never know what they did inside this
thing I hope they did something today
too well they did the memory thing for
the developers so right they they freed
up some more yeah
you get that clock speed a little closer
to the to the series X you mean
overclock a little bad boy yes
up a little highly yeah
little man having performances
larger magazines a selection of grips
insane are you stealth players out there
will surely need a suppressor
I want oh what's that starfish
what's fun for the player
you can stab them
you know there's a regular shotgun yeah
completely overhauled our combat
it's more Dynamic the animations are
more fluid
they haven't showed anything just where
they're kind of playing around with the
physics
no I want to say any other game we've
done before there's a lot of variety
gun
[Music]
gravity is different for each planet and
boost packages
[Music]
word
yeah I believe I can sort of grenade
launcher on these type of plants zero
gravity environments dude it's crazy
firing a ballistic weapon zero gravity
actually push you backwards
[Music]
for a more stable shooting experience
we also have mag weapons
I believe fish out some serious damage
now if they give you a performance mode
hey man
thank you
I'm gonna play in 30 anyway whether you
want to get up here on two fists if I
can get the graphical Fidelity weapons
like pistols
maybe you prefer something bigger
I put my TV in unreal let's go
a little bit of aliens in their life got
you covered they got a Gatling gun son
turn up on you
these damn thing they got a handheld
Gatling gun
hey you up shotgun see how many
selections of weapons he had yeah
oh that's crazy
we even got a little Jurassic Park for
your ass
with too much phosphorus
Frozen broken
shooting fire bullets
let's go
Gotta Walter P-38 James Bond damn it
How You Like Me Now robots too yeah hey
I took over that planet
that's gonna be us
oh this is gonna be sick
oh bye see you later homeboy see you
next show
wait a minute wait wait
what's the movie
oh thank you for being with us
oh yeah and spent it here
to take in there's a lot to the games
when I think about what makes it special
this game is a reflection of the
incredible the passionate team that made
it this is it all of them Game of the
Year candidates themselves into it
some of their favorite moments
my favorite part is every time you step
out on a planet it's a unique experience
you spend all this time building your
ship and you see it
these things are gigantic it's the kind
of thing that you just can't get
anywhere else there's something about
seeing a tower over in the distance
obviously I love the robot so much the
incredible amount of Worlds we created
sniper rifles come on lever actions
rocket launcher brain Sprout so a lot of
guys right now you'll probably hit me up
on Twitter
after this I'm going to be twiddling my
face that I enjoy most about the game
that's what you've come to expect from a
business but on a much bigger scale it
looks great yo he ran past the dude on
the beach
legs up look at the Stargate on behalf
of all of us
and make your own special moment
as well yeah where could I get the watch
I'm buying it right now
Todd send me the link
that'd be crazy here my DMs to send me
the link
I'll talk to Aaron
yeah I need that watch
or hit up Jason Ronald
yeah you know Big Star fails outside
they put they date out anyway Spider-Man
was like I don't want none of that smoke
right there now
console edition
comes with the Box
September 6th
all right 20 23.
feel the love
look at the sizzle reel give me that
Sizzle reel giving you that Sizzle feel
that fable
both
[Music]
did you get a lot DLC it's over here
baby
we got uh temper 21 remember for seven
month Lord bronze Todd already beat two
other Zelda games and he about to be
three oh against Zelda the game
with them games at we right here dogs
with him Dave said be right here dog
we must have gone through the shooting
that this is real
[Laughter]
yo that I ain't never good how you feel
[Music]
hey you know you know what you know
what's impressive the first party
Studios have plenty of variety yes sir
that's what matters yo you know it's
crazy more crazy impressive he probably
walked through the building and was like
yo who got something ready everybody put
their hands up we're gonna pick the best
and the brightest
[Laughter]
let's go forth you guys at the next show
let's go
oh look at that
these four horses in October Baby
they're throwing out names and dates Man
game pass looking mighty delicious this
year boys south of midnight like yeah
boy
hey they didn't announce anything for
that PlayStation service today
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so
as the king said are we going to jump
into this uh we're gonna pay some bills
right now so if everyone can just mute
their mics and we'll do that and then
we'll get into our reactions
all right
so give me a moment
this show is sponsored by betterhelp let
me ask you guys a question
how much time do you spend on yourself
in a given week versus how much time you
spend on other people how do you balance
those two things if you're even able to
balance them at all
it's very easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you and you
never take a moment to think about what
you need from yourself for me
tell me if you've heard this before it's
a broken record on this show I work a
whole lot of hours especially during the
week Monday through Friday
so the weekends belong to my wife my
family my friends here at iron Lords and
just everything else that I don't get a
chance to to do during the course of the
week now when you spend all your time
giving to others which is fine because
again I love all these people it can
leave you feeling a little bit stretched
thin and burnt out
therapy can give you the tools to find
more balance in your life so you can
keep supporting others without leaving
yourself behind
now for me while I haven't been to
therapy for the things that I just
talked about uh in in current things in
my life but many years ago I went
through a very difficult divorce and
although I felt a great weight had been
lifted from me I still found it very
difficult to navigate my feelings by
trying to get my life in order
I took the advice of my friends and
family and I decided to go to therapy
and I have to say that it helped me
immensely to focus on the positive
aspects of removing myself from a
toxicity a toxic situation while not
getting drowned by the emotional the
physical and the financial realities of
ending a 10-year relationship it helped
me to learn
the very positive it helped me to learn
positive organizational and coping
skills and how to set boundaries and it
also empowered me to strive to be the
very best version of myself
the great thing is that you know therapy
isn't just for the most traumatic
moments in our lives but it's also for
helping us deal with the stresses and
anxieties of our everyday lives so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule all you have
to do is go to the website fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and then if you
don't have a perfect match the first
time around that's fine this isn't a
perfect science you can just switch
therapists until you find a match for
you and you can do this as many times as
you need to for no additional charge so
if you need this type of help you can
find more balance with better help just
visit betterhelp.com iron Lords today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash ironlords
[Music]
thank you gentlemen thank you so much
no problem solved
yeah you know how it is everybody I have
to say
I have gotten so many DMS from people
who and it's it's baffling and amazing
to me people have 80 000 people watching
right now yeah that's a beautiful thing
people have DM me talking about let's
get those lights up sorry sir no no it's
great but
there's something to be said for peop
people who listen to you and just
appreciate you know our content whatever
that they have a trust in what we say
right and people hit me up in the DM
talking about hey man just listening to
to your story or whatever the case may
be I decided to give better help a try
and just therapy because something I
never thought I I that was for me so
again uh thank you to all of you who
kind of who take the things we say and
the things that we support
sort of seriously and and believe in
what we say because again we're not
going to support anything here there we
don't believe in it a scam or a lie or
whatever the case they actually take
Focus yeah so yeah it's a beautiful
thing so the ones the Wallace thing is
you know as men and I can't speak as a
woman because I'm not but as men
um a lot of times we're told to don't
cry
uh you know toughen up or uh you know
don't show any motion and we have we're
we're really beats the burden for
everybody that's in the house you know
whatever you know the buck stops with us
you know
if you're that guy right um and
something not taken away from any other
guys sometimes you know you have
different levels of stress but as men uh
we deal with stress on levels and we
don't have an outlet right usually we
are our own therapist and I think you
know better help helps that uh change
because when I started going to therapy
and it wasn't better helpful with my own
uh I noticed that uh it was a huge
change in myself personally how I dealt
with matters how I talk to people how I
internalize stuff and how I talk to
myself yep no because we have words that
we talk to ourselves and sometimes those
words aren't really nice so you know you
have to learn how to talk to yourself
better so it's good to go to therapy 100
so thank you to all of you to support
appreciate that and we will put that uh
that link in the chat
we'll do that now and we're about to get
to what we thought about the show in
general yes
General King is about to say his peace
hahaha
so uh who's gonna go first we're gonna
let our guests go first yeah let's go
let's go
quiet
for holding down the tech aspects behind
the scenes we appreciate you brother
yeah I was trying my best not to screw
this up I was like
you did a great job fantastic job thank
you thank you overall man um uh great
show great show it was um if I have to
I'm probably not I'm dying to watch this
thing on demand at 4K 60.
um but based off the immediate reactions
I'm going to say eight and a half
um uh 8.5 and I'll just start with the
things I uh I guess that was I guess
dissatisfied with one thing I was
dissatisfied with was the uh the lack of
uh Combat gameplay for hellblade to
um
which is I mean the game looks good we
already know that every time they've
shown in-game I believe that's what the
game's gonna look like it's it's fine
but I was hoping they just like you know
breaking like enemy and show us what
we're going to be doing
um and then this is disappointing for a
different reason this is more so my
expectations I was hoping just hoping
hellblade to will sneak in to this year
this year that close out the year with
you know star film reports so that was
more so like a sort of a a letdown but
and the other thing is during the
Starfield gameplay which I was you know
like feel really really focused that's
where I was quiet because they were
talking and they were letting hints drop
and every time the the lead tech or the
designer or the combat dude I went to
see all right are they going to reveal
its performance and they did not clarify
uh the performance mode for consoles
um for Starfield maybe it comes in the
next coming days but I was hoping that
but other than that man overall the open
strong which I did not anticipate them
to open with Fable I figured they maybe
you know close with it but that thing
started looking like another a form for
a minute that's I was like wait they
showing us Hogwarts Legacy as far as
graphically I'm like oh
Fable
um I think that showed off well they
started the show very like very strong
and they kept it they kept up the
momentum they didn't have too many of
those uh I remember that showcase I
watched you guys a couple years ago it
did he was like give that tequila
it wasn't yeah there was not too many of
those there like and I'm like okay so
and the fact that when Hellboy came in I
was like all right they did I was like
Hellboy they're not closing with
hellblade they didn't close with evolved
but they both showed up and they both
showed up in a big way
um and I'm excited to again rewatched it
because we were watching the 1080p
twitch stream I don't really like the
quality of twitch but I kept pressing
over to the side because it was playing
also on my TV at 4K I'm like oh wow oh
it's crazy and it looks crazy so
um the only thing is is that uh
next year you know pretty much Xbox
their first part they're coming in hard
like I'm happy to see compulsion finally
reveal their game uh with the south of
the south of the midnight I think it was
called uh south of midnight yeah yeah
and um in Exile with their steampunk RPG
uh uh that one is called the the clock
Clockwork Revolution that that looks
like it's that leg's Gonna Make some
noise and um it's happy to I'm happy to
hear and see from the Xbox Studios and
then you start thinking about the
studios that you didn't hear from and
then um the only thing again that makes
it like kind of ho-hum is
the fact that all right for the rest of
the year it's really like the Starfield
and Forza which essentially has to blow
our our socks off when we get in our
hands uh to close out the air and that's
really the disappointing part it's like
it's just it's not that they're bad
games it's like I think they need at
least one more game uh to send off the
year because when you consider star
field and Forza we've known these games
were supposed to come out years prior if
you think about it right so um that's
where it becomes disappointed but
overall the Showcase
um best showcase easily of the summer
um so far what we had in my opinion
um I've all the games that were shown at
this uh event look great and I have
interest in
um and a lot of the games that a lot of
games I anticipate have now been
displayed at this uh showcase so they
did a wonderful job there though I
thought they started strong ended strong
start I and I'm I'm not the biggest fan
of Bethesda game studios is hard to sell
me on these long drawn out RPGs but they
sold me on Starfield I will be eager to
try and try to get invested in that game
that's what's up
you're already doing what it is baby
first of all I'm gonna say it's a 10 out
of 10. I've seen every I've seen and and
let me say this I told people on a few
podcasts last week people said oh this
has to kill Sony show no no no
this show has to be good for us as Xbox
fans that's not to do it no other
company I don't care what the mother
shows did I don't care what games they
didn't show I wanted to see the money
that y'all invested in these companies
come to fruition I needed to see first
party bangers I wanted to see all the
stuff that we fantasize about oh I need
otherwise I need a valve I need this I
need that and they gave you exactly from
the beginning to the end they gave you
every single game games that me going to
2024 but we got to see gameplay
everybody was begging for fable out the
door slam dunk game is over they didn't
play no games and that's what I wanted
to see I wanted to see what you have
forget the third party partners because
those games is everywhere show me why I
invested 542 dollars in the console day
one yeah and they did that and they did
that that's the only thing that's the
only thing I want it and then they hit
us with other bangers we didn't even
know what's coming
Bill said
I will show you games you will see games
that you've never even heard before we
got that
Starfield
oh we don't know what it is just that
the third the the the the the walk
through we got that nobody if you wanted
60 or 30 I'm telling you it's gonna be
30. just leave it but you ain't gonna
say well I'm not playing it especially
after that showcase everybody on board
now anybody got rid of the Xbox was
coming right back
be right back what else could you
possibly ask everybody right yo listen
what what could you ask for you want a
game play you got it you wanted details
you got it they gave you everything
everybody in the chat I'm watching the
chat everybody is lit nobody was like
man that game's not my feet oh no no no
no
got one houses 200 people watching let's
get those likes over a thousand let's go
straight bang almost there let's go
did you cry man tears is the question
it is
I thought it was like a solid experience
I was really disappointed with the lack
of uh hell play two gameplay yeah
moves said the same thing
all right that's it all right so yeah so
what I'm saying is after we we really we
we really needed that right because yeah
let's not let's be real here almost down
everything banked on this show we had a
bad few months you know what I'm saying
so we really needed this and as as
Gamers we're excited to see great stuff
but when you when you say this is an
Xbox showcase we want to see Xbox stuff
yeah so that to me I agree 100 man it is
to me they needed to show if you think
about it
they showed the games from first party
that we didn't know what they were
exactly right they showed compulsions
game they showed obviously I talked
about about whatever
um everything else we kind of know what
it is we know what Perfect Dark is we
know there's other stuff in the pipeline
there are some Stills obviously some
Secrets out there still but to me this
was the fact that it was Xbox first
party after Xbox first party after Xbox
first party I was like I was I was
watching it in the car while driving in
I'm like damn it's one after the other
one after the other I was like yo they
really they're doing it and then
obviously
the things that would have really really
popped besides the first party stuff
that kind of got leaked the Persona
stuff that would have been huge and the
fact that it's going into game pass that
would have been ten times more both of
them both both of them that that is
Bonkers to me I gotta that I almost I
almost willing to give up my knees over
that even though it's not personally six
because it's going in the game pass that
is something else and Persona 3 is
beloved beloved because it is the start
of that formula that everybody loves
with Persona 5. the Persona 3 kind of
really started that so um for that to
come back and be a Game Pass is a
special thing man and they showed out
even with the third party stuff they
showed either Star Wars you know I'm a
little funny sometimes about their you
know first party third party stuff and
what I expect to be mostly first party
stuff but the Star Wars was crazy you
want to see more of it at Ubisoft
forward tomorrow
cool
um but everything from first party and
like 108 alluded to it's all all of it
looks great and all of it is varied
you're not seeing you're not you're not
seeing everything kind of looking the
same and stuff like that and I get it
that third person over the shoulder
that's what we consider Banger Hellboy
is going to be there and I totally agree
with smooth on the fact that man I
really wanted to see that combat because
to me the combat is where that game is
going to live and die because everything
else
the story stuff the stuff with the with
the with the multiple personalities and
the voices talking to her we know they
can get that right I I know the fields
are gonna be there but the combat in the
first one was very basic whatever but
they but but a Ninja Theory is very good
with combat they have always been there
so I really want to see them step it up
with that and really make this into an
action game they can gravitate to a lot
of people but I was super impressed and
again I've had my reservations about
Starfield
because for me it's just one of those
things where it's like man I don't want
to be a vast ocean that's ankle deep
right right what we saw today was not
that
there are aspects of it that again we
talked about the faces we talked about
this that the other way when you're
creating a game of this scope you're
gonna have to have some concessions it's
just a fact like the real console game
could really do that and be get there
um and uh to be perfectly honest there's
no better team than Todd's team to be
able to realize that type of vision
um so I'm excited to play it man I'm
excited to play it I have a feeling we
talked about this I think last week
about what they talk about the frame
rate here whatever if it was 16 they
would have mentioned it so I don't think
it's 60. but listen he came out and said
listen I like 30 frames yeah
the community keep pushing them listen
he says I like 30 frames and you know
what I was impressive about this
right it's his creative it's his
creative thing
but this this was crazy
they showed what what they really show
and display to everybody that your
investment into Game Pass is even more
it's warranted it's going crazy oh the
Capricorn game the yo the Capcom game
looks awesome taking something new again
sometimes you think about hey man they
can't get rid of evil whatever they got
a new Capcom IP to be shown first on
there on their stage and that's an
awesome thing about and it because it
shows Above All Else and in the atlas
Sega thing also it just shows that the
relationship is there the the the the
what you would call it the path to these
conversations about certain games that
PlayStation always gets first things of
that nature all of those conversations
are continuing to happen and again as
game past grows the reason to put these
games onto Game Pass and Xbox period
continues to be more compelling so for
me it a really really really showed out
today I'm so happy I like happens to
yourself I like Atlas yeah I didn't I
didn't see the number six though
because that game pass that game pass is
real I like I'll give you a half beneath
for that I appreciate it all right
the battle still rages the battle rages
on
it was something else so let's before we
go to to to the king General King yeah
let's see what the laws that were in the
building have to say let's go it's
different in here man like you already
see the energy was super high the way
they set it off with fable fable looking
crazy to me like that joint graphically
like
listen write down overall I'm debating
between the eight and the nine I got a
little bit only because
the game look the show was amazing let's
just get that off the way they killed
that right now it's about how great was
it my only nitpick was hellblade I was
hoping for some some combat yeah
so I gotta nitpick a little bit that and
then there was a couple of this is I
don't know composer Joys look good but
like there's a little instance where I
was like I gotta see a little bit more
from you but I will say in Exile yeah
I'm not sure that look crazy they showed
out on third part they showed out on
Indies but I think it's over with what
the hell song I feel this now I think we
could put that the rest with oh yeah
we know what it is
the only thing you could say is if yeah
they say it was 30 or 60.30 energy but I
don't get did you see what you can do
with this game yeah yeah
it's crazy bro so for me
right now I'm in that 8.5 kind of Zone
Starfield oh I won't say this song
at first I was disappointed that uh one
more thing wasn't
another game another game in the main
show as if they was nervous
because that's what you're gonna think
about it they show the game for the
people that's not going to watch
Starfield right it was like they would
probably nervous that people wouldn't
stay for the direct so you got to give
them a little something a little
something I will say even though I was
disappointed at first that the one more
thing wasn't a new game
how they showed out with Starfield was
so ridiculous yeah was so insane I was
like nah they did they were getting that
this year and I was like they did that
you can't combat everything looked good
again the only thing he would say is
whether or not it's performance mode or
not it don't feel like it's going to be
but I will say I don't care that game
for me yo and a vowel bro oh wow
that's crazy but yeah the energy crazy
in here man everybody out here showing
out bro the building the roof was crazy
I'm telling y'all man but I heard the
whole the line stuff was crazy over
there Aaron was outside moving moving
the whole crowd moving everybody yelling
Hold the Line crazy so King I need the
channel where you at
well
live from the battlefield we heard the
opposition brought a knife to a gunfight
and Microsoft brought bazookas
[Laughter]
is the general British today is what I
want to know it's like British accent
today
foreign
I told you
June 11th it was D-Day for you pause
[Music]
[Laughter]
you got Banger after Banger first part
we believe in Generations here
we believe in first party studios here
we have the best and the brightest
at no point in time did you see TV
did you see a movie trailer
racing game it was actual cars in a
racing game
Listen People you have been repping the
wrong people
over here at Xbox we'll take you in
that's right it'll go nice with your
Miles Morales Spider-Man
we believe in ssds over here
all the stuff that we say is actual
factual so we shout out with the show I
got to get a show a 9.5
I gotta deduct the five uh for uh
hellblade not showing uh actually no
combat I feel you that's it I feel you
Jennifer they did they did not talk they
walked the wall
she said at this point in time I would
like you to take your wallet Fold It Up
and mail it to Aruba
because your wallet is going on vacation
pack game pass everything Game Pass
anything all day bangers yeah it was
like they went through the building and
was like who got games to present
is done
the fight is over I told y'all to hold
the line shout out to everybody that's
holding the line everybody that went and
held the line
go to Teespring store you got no crying
today if you're a PlayStation dude in
your recovery
because the war has won
your show was terrible we welcome you
over here so General
on the neck energy what's the energy
it's Crocs on the neck energy it's
cracks on the neck energy
we got combat cracks
get your combat apparel
we was ready for that war you worry
you came in with a knife
we had the blicky
I told you
heavyweight champ yeah they did that
defeated they did that
Microsoft I told you this is the rise of
Dolph film
this is the day
this is the day when you see there's no
going back to the old ways
on the show I gotta ask like how did you
feel to create a whole movement where
people believe again and they back in
line listen man because you know what it
is
sometimes you need to see that light in
the darkness and you know I had to roll
out and I said Megatron Must Be Stopped
no matter what the cost
yeah
and we stop right now they ain't looking
the same the dancing squeak yeah and
they ain't got no games
this year and next year we sold it up
so real quick question
um were you doing ratings yet
yes sir I rated it in 9.5 I'm giving
that 8.5
I feel like a point for
um a point for hellblade I got half a
point on how I feel like last of like
solid concrete release date it's like we
got windows but I like especially a
valid and hellblade I wanted like
concrete release dates but besides that
you know some of the indie games that
really apply to me but I saw how white
some people would find them appealing
I don't know yeah you know people don't
mind seeing Indies at showcases they
want to see it needs that look of
healing to a lot of people and I feel
like they did that
very well let's get Wolverine I have to
get 8.5
yeah yeah am I right where we at baby I
gave it a 10.
it looks fantastic wow I would like to
see it but I'm not taking no points for
that because the whole show was amazing
we only seen two people for two minutes
right that's what games games games
games games for Xbox
Xbox
yo it was crazy
we got dates Capcom bend the knee
we got other companies I mean what what
can you say really yeah we probably I'm
probably out of nine I gotta watch the
whole thing over again because for me I
was watching it in the car driving yeah
thank you beautiful 1K likes in one show
we still got a thousand plus people
watching guys remember the last one of
you as we wrap up this show because
we're not doing four hours
so so for me nine so far and I again I I
was watching it all in in the car
watching it all the way up until the
Fallout 76 stuff and then that's when I
arrived I had to leave and get upstairs
or whatever right so so that's I because
I felt kind of like the energy might be
going down a little bit because it was
starting to show the the things that had
the show right yeah so I feel like the
live Services look at like unless you
have giant expansions I feel like to see
if these ones a little bit made more
sense because that was that made 100
sense yeah yeah it was though
from long distance I don't know I don't
know I
I want to get
one thing I will say about fables is it
does look like they have a good comment
like they met me in the middle grade
that playground engine it looks like
they're doing a lot of humor but it's
like less crazy ways than they did in
the previous one oh that's okay that's
crazy see y'all later all right
we'll listen to your Tweet
yeah that's it we that's it that is our
initial impression so next week we'll
probably talk about it more in depth
especially if any more news comes out in
the Xbox extended showcase right we're
gonna have some more stuff going on uh
tomorrow we have Ubisoft as well so
maybe some more Xbox Centric stuff I had
hoped to see Splinter Cell
you know what they did they did 12
months without telling you 12 months bro
kind of connoissota right they did 12
months without telling you 12 months
they they said you know what we ain't
gonna say it no more we're just gonna do
it yeah you realize that it you just you
just set up a rake for yourself when you
don't do it saying things no just do
yeah and then obviously the dates will
speak for themselves right but again
when you don't put it in in writing that
way then you have wiggle room where you
have to move right right and that's it
so all right well
it's been great I want to thank
everybody for showing up being great
thanks for having the kids move for
hosting yes holding it down because uh
King and I are dumb when it comes to
that oh yeah
plus I'm wearing shade you so I had to
wear the glasses to read the Super Chat
shops
it's coming watch it arrive tomorrow
but you see it's it's new Eddie days
like Game Pass yo shout out to 108
dragons my boy uh yeah when I when I
said uh who I was gonna do the show with
um I definitely said I was reaching out
to win a weight Dragon uh I love his
energy I love what he brings to The
Gaming Community
this is a guy who puts his uh his show
on his back he purchases all this stuff
all the stuff that you see all those
giveaways that's him man that's not
funded by anybody else that's just him
he's passionate about this game and
stuff he's gaming agnostic so that means
that he games everywhere he just prefers
the game on Xbox and he wrecks Xbox but
he games everywhere and he's the epitome
of a stand-up stick behind you dude
that's my dude he's always been in my
corner you know uh I love you oh y'all
and that's my block brother so one-way
dragons let the people know exactly
where they can find you and uh what's up
yo one away dragon's TV on everything
man it was a pleasure being here you
know I love being with my brother's man
and shout out to my brothers over there
in L.A you know what I'm saying y'all
doing that thing but runaway dragon's TV
and everything and appreciate y'all for
having me facts kids move my brother
from another mother this dude has been
down he's a rap artist he he's a
hard-working family man he's a YouTuber
he's an influencer he's a provoker he's
a provocateur my man has had the one
chip challenge is still the best one
chip challenge on YouTube the greatest
reactions ever to the website hell yeah
man yo you put fear in my heart my heart
yo telling people where they can find
you and what what you got going on
brother yeah man you can find uh me on
uh kiss movie Kiss move Twitter at his
move also on uh the new version of
playing Xbox with me and Laura the attic
uh which you're gonna be doing tonight
and it'll be on uh the weapon with
patreon uh for you guys to watch tonight
immediate reactions but thank you guys
for having me
um and uh yeah man we look forward to
the next one uh you'll trust me when
that hold the line shirt comes in I'll
have a video prepared so I can flaunt it
and
um if I could get you know hold the line
song coming through
get together let me say something before
we get out of here let me say something
let me say something I want y'all to
check out my ASU raw coverage this week
go we're gonna have I got mad
accessories I got the unboxing coming I
got the um SSG exchange I'm gonna show
you how to do it and then we're gonna
get into performance in the last video
in different games so just pay attention
and look out for those on one way
dragons TV backs facts yeah look out for
that during the week we will we will
have it we will have questions on Sunday
as well because I'm getting it yeah the
fomo got me so I'm getting it um Chicago
have it as well so we'll we'll talk a
little bit about it on the show as well
and one more thing thanks to my brothers
I gotta shout y'all out for this I got
that Volari Halo edition gold I'm coming
because my brothers is them dudes man
thank you for Larry and shout out to
y'all for that opportunity that will be
dropping also I'm also working on that
video too facts blessings fantastic my
man soft came in say today with the
super chats he slid in the back door
waving the football I told you Atlas
don't hit him no more my man so what's
up baby my apologies for coming in hot
but you know I had to I didn't honestly
once the E3 got folded I was like okay
it's folded for us we're not doing
anything and then opportunities
presenting themselves and and it was the
best thing that could have happened
because Cog and and addict uh in La is a
beautiful thing this past week they did
some fantastic things so loved them
appreciate them going out there and
hustling on behalf of all of us King my
brother you know I mess with you when
you when you when you go because you go
you go for XBox and and I love Xbox but
I got I like slapping around a little
bit sometimes it'll make me happy but
they made me happy today
um but to see the entire Community
gravitate to hold the line and it become
this movement where Xbox execs are
talking about it wearing this shirt and
showing love uh it's a special thing it
really is a special thing and only it's
really only you can do that bro you only
you can Corral troops in this way
because you just really
yeah Charisma is on another level and I
just love the fact that every
opportunity we get to show more people
that I'm like who is this Kingdom what
does this hold the line thing it's a
beautiful thing so I'm just so excited
for for what holds the line what door is
that is open
um and but thank you because again
you're you're only you only you can do
that
and it's always been that way brother
it's always been that way I'm just so
happy that everybody gets a chance to
see it now but yeah thank you guys for
holding me down uh came in real hot but
I'm excited uh for what's coming the
rest of the year I'm gonna see some more
games right there's more games to talk
about
um but Xbox looks like we're gonna be
eating good real real soon and that is
I'm excited about that well I I I want
to say thank you everybody that uh
supported Hold the Line uh it's organic
um that's you know round Foods that's us
uh and I just felt that you know we
needed a voice I heard a lot of
dissension a lot of dudes you know
wondering what we're going to do a lot
of dudes and we're going to stand right
here we're gonna hold the line because
the hit's gonna keep coming we're going
to have faith and you know if we trust
in uh the process we have to stick to
the process that's a lot of times people
aren't successful because they turn
around before the process is completed
and you're halfway through you got to
stick through the process and we saw the
fruits of their labor today with the
process all those Studios that purchase
all those Studios those games showed up
they had the best and the brightest and
when you really start to dissect exactly
what they did they showed you what their
games or Services is they showed you
what cloud was they showed you what
their first party was and they listened
to everything that everybody said and
they just came with nothing but bangers
they did not talk they did not show you
no personalities they went 100 for the
juggler and this is what I want to see
from uh Microsoft I want to see
Microsoft go straight for the Juggalo
when Sony fumbles you kick them right in
the rear down them steps you make sure
that they don't get up and right now
Sony is broken so oh I know y'all got
Final Fantasy and I feel kind of good
but man God bless uh that's it uh you
know at some point in time
um trust me
um and you know they got Spider-Man
coming this year so you know they eating
good over there but you know a lot of
stuff that we're eating a little bit
better it's Ebbs and flows so you ain't
gotta run no place but when you're
gaming agnostic and I'm gonna say this
when you're gaming agnostic
you don't have to worry about that you
can watch every show with uh love that
you're supposed to watch it with but
if you only got one money to pay
choose Xbox because they got you
love you guys peace no don't lie to that
we still got we got to pay some real
quick uh bills some super chats and then
we out then we're out hold on a second
we got Robert kellett two dollar Super
Chat strong a minus show overall very
impressed no doubt Jax 82 five dollars
to protect King I've been I've been a
frustrated Xbox fan you brought me back
with hold the LIE yes he did a lot of
people a lot of people man beautiful got
four is a legend member for two years
two dollar Super Chat going to need the
best headphones for headphones the best
headphones with headphones yeah I feel
then we got Exton Dio Taco five dollars
who attacked the only two things keeping
it from being a perfect show was no
combat for hellblade everybody kind of
said that yeah facts and not even a
snippet of gameplay for south of
midnight yeah maybe maybe Xbox one
yeah yeah then we have kieran717 five
dollar Super Chat the sleeping giant has
finally been awoken since Lord Phil
wasn't playing today no he was not he
was not then we got Cowboys fan 404 10
super chat if Scorpio was third party
Sony Fanboys would be eating this game
up yes you know how the discourse goes
this is the tail is all this time that's
console Wars next on the otaku two
dollar Super Chat how did in Exile show
more gameplay than hellblade yes that
was that was disappointing for sure
then we got Spartan go 17 to pound Super
Chat Xbox extend showcase June 13th more
reveals question mark could be
absolutely could be and then our final
one we have parasite 82 green five pound
super chat in the words of common out of
everybody who told the truth time did
looks like our patience is finally paid
off Xbox owners be eating good soon yes
and we all caught up thank you guys once
again peace peace we'll see y'all next
week peace